[Music]
here's so [ __ ] cute okay yeah let's
do this [ __ ]
what's up I'm Kristen Stewart and I'm
elavil Insco this is first impressions
for Tyla nice to be taken out right here
did you not take from the top I just
sort of went for it now okay this first
one so so basically yeah I just really
wasn't happy with like oh god you know
well is this could be so many yeah as
refresh I can't say key things can i ah
there's a one yes oh we got Sunday
service oh yeah yeah oh I'm gonna turn
the color well I'm gonna go ahead and
carry out like I don't know what's wrong
with me that was so good I need to watch
everyone's now I'm gonna become like a
huge fan of this show okay oh wow
well I think I'm gonna change the green
oh wow that's fun
oh my god why is why I'm so ready
okay wait um she goes like I'm getting
votes I'm getting like headset
microphone yeah saying yeah okay
I can't think I grew up in the 90s this
is crazy
we're fine down to an era Oh Oh baby
right oh yes I just um I don't anything
okay I was worse than this this is so
embarrassing you know I just
especially you know I just I feel like
we should just just don't even think
about it let's not even think let's just
go
is this an impression yes dude and you
just said
wait are you doing me oh god I thought
you were just freaking out yeah because
of me yeah because that makes sense yeah
yeah yeah I was like god this is what I
look like when I'm freaking hell oh man
well good job that actually was great
I'm so meta and like weird okay let's do
this yeah no you did great yeah no you
guys you killed it goodbye just kind of
listen to what I say and then she'll
take it all right okay I feel like I
feel like I'd need like uh I mean use
this like a beard okay
yes hurry but not that person that I now
realize I look like I'm doing Harry a
buddy Scottish Rite he or something or
it I think cuz he's Scottish as well I
think there's a Scottish old person oh
it is this guy donkey
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a media
[Music]